don't worry gracie
the curtain only goes up when everyone
has a part to play
oh okay i got you oh whoa watch out for
those audio cables
i'm gonna be sick
i am not going out there without crazy
neither am i
um a little help no pressure
well that is not pixar's newest movie
although it does look a lot like it
those are characters
and they're actually local theater
students from thurman white academy alex
yes that's so cool
they weren't able to put on their play
during the pandemic so they got creative
and got a really cool opportunity hector
mejia live at the school in henderson
this morning with the details
good morning hector
good morning you know this is a really
heartwarming local student a local
student a heartwarming
local story that includes 22
local students and an academy
award-winning
director and joining us live we have
stephanie with cots las vegas to tell us
first of all
before we run out of time when does this
air and on what channel
sure drawn closer the short film
actually premieres
on may 9th on cox channel 14 or 1014
which is our year review network
if you really are itching to see a
teaser you can go on youtube
and just look for drawn closer and
you'll see the teaser so cox
communications is behind this animated
short film
tell us number one why and how it even
happened
you know for us hector it's really about
leveraging our technology to
to make those human connections and we
all know during quarantine
when all the kids were sent home there
were no human connections everybody was
isolated
they were pulled away from their friends
the things that they loved most like
sports and music and theater
and when we learned about thurman white
and the play that they had planned and
they weren't able to do their play
it really just broke our hearts and we
thought how can we make this a reality
for kids
to be able to be on the stage even
though it would be a virtual stage
and that's how the whole idea of drawing
closer was born
and it's the first time cox
communications does something like this
with a local
school anywhere in the country right yes
it is we've done a lot of things in the
education sector around the country but
this is the first time we've actually
produced a film and
it started out as just a play and
expanded play and then
then we contacted patrick osborne the
director
and he said sign me up and he helped us
with the animation and the directing and
the voicing
and the kids just lit up they did a
phenomenal
phenomenal job on that note you know we
have to talk with the kids too
they're here they've been here all
morning long they got here before i even
got here so they've been here since
about 4 30 in the morning
we're right outside of the school guys
anything you guys want to say before we
let everyone go
um i just want to say a
giant thanks to cox yeah thank you to
cox communications for the opportunity
what was it like though insane yeah
uh unbelievable uh
they did a phenomenal job voicing their
parts they use these tablets that
created the animation opportunities for
them
so and they did it all from their homes
so very safely and then it was knitted
together to create this short film
that's really going to warm people's
hearts when they see it
and they've already been interviewed
nationally right by national network so
again it premieres
on may 9th on channel on channel 14
cox channel 14 or 10 14. and of course
every film needs a red carpet and they
actually had a red carpet premiere
and they got the glammed up star
treatment too i understand they did
all right well we'll be posting all of
those details on our website eight
newsnow dot com for now reporting live
from henderson
hector mejia alex and john back to you
that is fantastic
uh academy award-winning director local
kids getting to see themselves on screen
there must have been such a trip to be
able to see themselves
and hear their voices and see animation
is amazing
yeah it is so cool you tell ava and
everett good job from us yeah
here in the studio hector thank you
can't wait to watch it